the beat uh I talked to a lot of hip-hop
guys I forget which rapper I just
interviewed and they said that it was
like someone big who just said that two
million that was your their favorite
record I forget who the [__] it was but
that beat is infectious that sample is
crazy it's crazy how I even got that
beat because somebody else was rapping
on it when they sent it to me I guess
they wanted me to hear it and put a
verse on it or whatnot and I was like yo
let me get that
wait so it got sent to you to be a
feature facts or I think somebody may
have wanted me to hear it or
put a verse on it because they sent it
to me they had a verse on it or already
and [__] you know what I'm saying so
when I got it in my uh
email I'm like what the [__] you know
what I'm saying I'm gonna need that I
need that what happened to the guy whose
verse was on it oh no damn he probably
heard that [__] like [__] yeah he
probably did he probably hey I bet you
he's getting so much blood it ain't even
that though but you want to know why
because
anybody else could have made nobody
could have made the song I made facts in
Arkansas
so the beat and it's the thing because I
keep telling the engineer who made the
beat because we had kind of like class
you know what I'm saying
because he had agreed to a number and I
ain't gonna say the number
and when it when the song blew up he
wanted more he ain't want to sign off on
the on the on what he agreed on and he
didn't have no team no lawyers and none
of that [__] before the song came out so
when the song like I did
here come a new manager and a lawyer and
all this [__] you know what I'm saying
with these numbers and [__] but we ended
up working it out but I'm telling him
like bro
you made the beat but it was the we paid
this it was a sample in the beat
and you had to clear the sample
you had a paper so you had to add okay
some little bills and whistles or
whatever we can't take that away from
you but you could have gave that beat to
anybody else and it wouldn't have been
the song that I made you feel what I'm
saying so you can't sit up here and act
like you did something that you know
what I'm trying to say so if somebody
let's say like that particular guy is he
kind of can would you work with him
again no that's fair no I won't work
with him again I won't I don't like
working I really
I want to work with like in-house
producers man because it's tricky it's
different now it made it so difficult to
put out music right now it's like crazy
right to where you don't even want to
deal with producers if you only
personally know you know what I'm saying
yeah because then yeah now I feel you
because you we might we might have a
discussion in the studio and it's one
thing and then that lawyer drops that
email over but I ain't mad at I'm not
mad at how how I set up because the
producers do need their money in their
credit but sure how they got it set up
now
they allowing like lower level engine
lower level producers and tatars
like crazy numbers
based on based on who they think the
artist is right I think also too like
you got to look at like anybody not even
a producers artists anybody you gotta
like people should look at things the
Long play way
because like imagine if he would have
just been squared up with you and and
honored his word like we would have did
a whole album or something you know what
I'm saying [__] we made a hit together
let's make some more or orders or they
doing this too like they give you the
beat and it says free or not but when
it's time to put the record out they're
gonna charge
six seventh I like bro you know what I'm
saying yeah like you've never made that
much money they're sending it on the
invoice though like hoping the label
pair
myself like yo
come on bro right that [__] coming out
of my pocket do you help me out I'll
help you out